On March 16, the US Federal Reserve or the US Central Bank launched
a policy of raising interest rates for the first time in 4 years to control the rise
in prices or the inflation rate in the United States, which reached 7.9%, levels,
a first of its kind in forty years. It is a quarter of a percent 0.25%
and it will proceed toward raising interest rates until the end of this year, so to continue in 2023
As we clearly explained in the previous episode, which is very important to watch, and you can do so from here
As expected, some Arab central banks directly started raising interest rates,
such as the Saudi, Kuwaiti, Emirati and Bahraini central banks
as their currencies are affected by the value of the US dollar
Moreover, oil export contracts are currently being settled  in US dollars
The last Arab central bank to raise interest rates (until the time of filming this episode) was the Egyptian Central Bank
wherein it raised interest rates on Monday, March 21st, by 1%
All of this, of course, boosted inflation levels putting a burden on people's purchasing abilities
A crucial question pops up here: How should people be dealing with? How are they supposed to manage their financial affairs during times that witness a significant rise in price levels?
In today's episode, we will try to tackle some of the basic questions that are of interest to all of you
Certainly, I hope you understand that Discussion of all aspects of the matter can not be fully done in one episode
however, consider this episode as a beginning of a series of episodes on how to manage your financial matters,
dealing with the crises and challenges you face every day in order to overcome them in the right way
This episode will contain the most important initial advice, or a part from a simplified practical guide with clear solutions
Before we start, don't forget to subscribe to the channel, follow to cope up with all upcoming episodes
Give attention to what I am going to say from A to Z, as all the coming content is completely connected to each other
I am Ashraf Ibrahim and this is the ‘Economic Informant’..
I just want to say in the first place that this episode is sponsored by ‘Mostaqel’ company
It is the largest platform for Arab freelance work
Through Mostaqel , you can hire the best Arab freelancers remotely. You can also hire a programmer to build a website or a mobile app,
hire designers to design a logo for your project, writers, translators, marketers and others..
I personally use Mostaqel when I need any of those.. To know more about Mostaqel; check the link down below in the video description
Point one: Do not buy expensive or luxury goods
The rational person, in the simplest possible definition, is the one who acts according to reason or logic,
and therefore their behavior if making a financial decision will be in their financial interest
However, behavioral economists have discovered that a large proportion of the people do not act rationally
such as when they buy luxurious or expensive goods that they do not even need
According to many sober and significant studies, a large proportion of consumers who buy luxurious goods
are in a financial situation that does not allow them to buy these goods at all
Instead of someone buying a smart phone at a fair price that does all the required tasks that they may need
We find that many people choose to pay a lot of money to buy luxurious phone brands
just to show off the brand they were able to afford, no matter that this pricier phone performs the same functions that the fair price phone does
Well, if your financial capabilities allow you to buy this expensive phone, that's okay, do whatever you want
but why does someone with a 3 or 5 thousand Egyptian pound salary, for example,
afford to buy a phone or TV for 30 thousand pounds or more?
Behavioral economists say that this approach usually manifests a certain feeling of self satisfaction
wherein a person lacks self-confidence and does not respect themselves,
so when he/she buys these luxurious goods,
especially if they are financially unable, he/she enhances their self esteem, giving them more self confidence
The second reason is that a person’s purchase of luxurious goods,
though neither their income nor their financial capacity allows them to buy them easily,
is to generate a sense of belonging to an upper rich class,
this boosts a false sense of superiority to everyone around them, to be satisfied with their social class so to speak
However, sometimes this feeling turns against you
According to a study conducted by Boston College and Harvard Business School
spending your money on luxurious things is likely to lead to negative outcomes making you feel worse than before
This uncomfortable feeling that you feel after purchasing a luxurious good you can not financially afford and you don't need
is called the impostor syndrome from luxury consumption. Boston and Harvard researchers gave the study the same name
lest I bore you with this, you can never measure the value of yourself or success
by exaggerating the consumption of luxuries good in general,
otherwise, the result will be a shortcoming in things you actually need,
and an increase in the size of your debts reaching levels that you cannot repay afterwards,
thus wrecking your financial situation
To proceed with the second point, don't buy goods whose prices have been subjected to price shaking
Simply put, there are commodities which prices have risen dramatically in the recent few days
in a way that is not commensurate with their costs on the real ground
This happens as a result of an exaggerated reaction from the companies producing these commodities
motivated by greed and desire to make the best profit of the current  tense situation
However, when the situation gets better, these goods will come close to their fair price
Moving on to the second important point: Do not be carried away by installment offers
Can you imagine it when the same person whose salary is 5 thousand pounds goes to buy a phone for 30 thousand pounds in installments?
And this is often what happens because he simply does not have cash
Certainly, you have noticed the emergence of new companies in the Arab world
whose business model is all based on installment sales,
whether this commodity is sold at interest or at the price of cash
These companies are the equivalent of “buy now, pay later” companies that exist in the West
In general, the business of installment companies flourishes much more in times of economic crisis
because people are tired of their financial conditions and they resort to buying in installments as a consequence
In a nutshell, I have two problems with buying in installments, and they are enough to keep you away from it completely
I hope you pay attention as this point is really important..
The first problem: that installment offers make you more susceptible to what behavioral economists call Impulsive buying,
which is a term that means making purchases of goods or services
without planning for them and often without you needing them
In other words, you suddenly rush and buy something
because you were exposed to an outside stimulus, you are doing this without thinking
For example, you only have 10 thousand pounds,
so if you think about buying luxuries or something that is not necessary,
you may be able to buy a slightly expensive watch that you do not need
But if you decide to buy goods in installments, you can buy the expensive watch,
iPhone, PlayStation and sun glasses if possible. All you need
is to pay the first installment of each of these goods, and when it is the time to pay the rest of the installments,
you may be able to figure out how to manage them
The rest of these installments take us to the second problem,
which is the possibility of defaulting on paying the installments,
especially if you do not have certain assets that you can sell to pay the indebtedness
The installment is a debt that must be paid my dear, and if you do not pay in time , you will get into troubles, in addition to paying interest for delaying, you may be imprisoned as well, God forbid.
One might say that this is a weak and unlikely possibility,
well, according to a study conducted by the American company Credit Karma
about 40% of users of “buy now, pay later” services failed to pay at least one of the installments
in America, this implicated them in late fines
Last Year, 2021 In Australia, the Afterpay company collected $64.6 million in late fines from installment service users
Of course, this will leave you in a terribly bad mood which may last for months or years until you pay off your debts or installments
Unfortunately the working environments in the Arab region are considered unstable
in other words, you may find yourself jobless at any time, with your income being cutted off, so how will you be able to pay your installments?
That's why I highly recommend buying in cash if possible
As the saying goes, If you can't afford something, think twice about whether you really need it or not
and don't forget the first point that we discussed before
The third point: raise your value to increase your income
Any good or service has a price, Your effort at work has a price which is the salary you receive at the end of each month
If you look around, you will find people doing the same job as you and getting paid more than you.. Why?
Perhaps because they are more experienced than you, this is one of the main reasons indeed,
therefore you have to raise your value for a salary hike. This isn't a HR talk
You should not waste your time even if you have finished your daily tasks,
as long as there is still spare time you have got to learn whatever skills you lack.
If your salary is 5,000 pounds here in Egypt, ask yourself, what is the difference between you
and those who receive 10,000 and 15,000 pounds in the same field? Skills or experiences!
Well, sharpen your enthusiasm, get your skills augmented, gain experience
and last but not least make your goal to reach the same position.
As I previously said, watch the time you spend as it tends to be what you are on now
The Fourth point: do not quit your job to follow your passion
Yes, I’d strongly advise anyone not to leave their stable job to follow their passion or enthusiasm especially in times of global economic crisis,
be wise, do not take risks in such times as this will probably cost too much.
If your job ends at 4 or 5 PM then you have from 5 to 9, may be even 10 PM, as spare time, five hours per day in which you can follow your passion
whatever the way you wish, learn new skills, discover new fields - do whatever you want,
if you are a head of a family and busy with responsibilities making you have no spare time After work,
just keep your job, do not resign as long as you have no other guaranteed source of income
Only if you have a better job offer with more advantages do it
I highly recommend not quitting your job to launch a private business.
On the other hand, establish a company or a project while you still are in your job,
no matter how hard to cope up with both, never leave your job
unless your project is really fruiting needing your full focus and there is a solid ground opportunity among other competitors in the market
The fifth point: Don't be reckless in launching business
Yes, I mean it, in times of economic crises and recession, do not launch a business recklessly
Of course, there are great opportunities in times of economic crises, but such difficult times are dangerous, and you are not a millionaire after all
You may lose the money you have and become financially broken,
so please do not waste your money on a project you barely studied
Do not invest in a field until you carefully study it in detail, consult domain experts,
and the greatest experience remains that you work in this field with your bare hands
Do you want to open a restaurant? Then work in a restaurant. Do you want to run a used-car business? work in a used-car showroom, and so on
Be careful! Don't rush out and pool your money in a mutual fund company, as these types of  financial vehicles are not trusty
You may think that things will work differently with you and you may be the exception,
I do not think so, my dear! Sure you can be the exception but this is less likely to happen, the more likely it is that you will lose your money and remain broke
Most people always think of themselves as the exception, and this is not wrong, by the way
Ambition is a positive attitude. The mistake is that you are really acting as an exception
According to National Business Capital, an American company specialized in financing and servicing small businesses;
90% of small projects or small companies fail
What is meant by small companies here are those that have 500 employees or less, do you get me?
90%! So, slow down, be wise, think twice about every step, and consult domain experts
Sixth point: Regarding gold
First of First, let us quickly get acquainted with the state of gold prices
On the day of the US Federal Reserve’s decision to raise the interest rate, which is March 16,
an ounce was worth 1917 dollars, after the decision was issued the second day,
the gold prices rose to 1950 dollars, and then they went down again at the time of filming the episode
to approximately 1925 dollars, Why did the Fed's decision not reduce gold prices?
Simply because raising interest rates by a quarter percent by the Federal Reserve
was not enough amid the uncertainty that the global economy is experiencing now,
therefore the market was not affected as expected. It could have been affected if the raise was half percent for example.
This is what one of the members of the Federal Open Market Committee, James Pollard, actually voted for,
but most of the committee members saw that 0.50% could cause a shock to the markets,
so they decided to start with a of 0.25% and continue to raise during the upcoming sessions,
as there are still 6 meetings scheduled for the US Federal in 2022.
It is likely that the US Federal Reserve will raise the interest rate in each session by 0.25%,
the meeting will take place in two consecutive days. Keep attention to these dates as they are of a huge significance:
May 3/4 - June 14/15 - July 26/27 - September 20/21 - November 1-2 - December 13/14.
It is expected that gold prices will decline as the US Federal Reserve continues to raise interest rates.
In the same context, why did gold prices rise in Egypt after the devaluation of the pound?
Naturally, its prices rise due to currency differences, as is the case with other commodities that are linked to international prices
The rise in its price after the devaluation of the pound is due to purely local reasons and has nothing to do with global prices.
Well, given current events, Should we buy gold or not?
In my personal opinion, which you may agree or disagree with,
I do not prefer buying gold at these high prices, which are 1925 dollars an ounce,
as it will probably decrease during the coming months, so one would better wait until its price drops below 1750 dollars an ounce and then buy it
As we explained before, you must buy spikes, not gold crafts
choose a reputable company that has a good reputation in the market, don't buy from small or unknown shops just because the workmanship is less
There are reputable Arab companies now, you can sign up for an account to sell and buy gold starting from 10 grams and above and in ounces as well
Considering Buying gold, one cannot say that it is an investment in the literal sense of the word, but it will save you your assets from inflation
To be fully aware of the gold do and don'ts, watch the episode we previously published in the playlist below..
Point seven: Health is the most important thing
Economists and experts see health from a farther and deeper perspective as one of the most important financial assets
To be accurate, it is the most vital and valuable asset our Lord Almighty gave us for free, so one must preserve it
Preventing diseases saves you huge amounts of money, other than the wasted times that cost other huge sums,
there are dozens of economic studies and researches that measure the economic costs of disease,
and among the costs of disease are what economists call the value of lost output,
and this is the result of stopping or declining productivity,
and it affects not only you and your financial status, but the economy of the entire country
Your body must be preserved as much as possible in order to stay well and not be financially drained in the long term,
and therefore maintain your health, sleep enough, eat healthy food as much as possible, reduce fast food, and consume as much as possible according to what is available
Certainly, neither you nor me have the same options considering our health status that Cristiano Ronaldo of course has
Cut down on junk food, sugars and unhealthy food
So, this is possible for anyone to apply regardless of their financial level and we all know this. Do this an everyday routine, then if you get sick it would be the lord's will,
and this is another separate issue, may God heal everyone,
but other than that, there are many steps that you can take in advance to preserve your health with a little hard work.
To make myself short, as I said, there were some suggested steps to reduce the effects of the crisis and overcome the shock of price hikes.
You may agree or disagree with me about them. In the end, they are just personal viewpoints, but they are based on specific,
informational and logical data, so let us discuss what I have said in the comments below, and if anyone has other suggestions
please type them down in the comments as well.
We will try to cope up with your best pieces of advice and post it with the names of its authors on all our social media platforms, God willing.
Other episodes like this may be coming soon, in which I will discuss  proposed solutions to properly manage our financial status,
I will discuss in details some of the points I have mentioned in today's episode,
that’s why you need to subscribe to the channel to see all our episodes,
activate the ring icon, tell your friends about us, They may like it too, Goodbye.